CUSTOMER DOES HE REALLY ADORE
ERIC SWALWELL AS HE PRETENDED TO
IN THE PICTURE CUSTOMER PROBABLY
NOT.
JESSE WATTERS HAS STUDIED THIS
PARTICULAR REPORT.
HE IS THE AUTHOR OF THE
FANTASTIC BOOK, "HOW I SAVE THE
WORLD."
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM JOIN US
TONIGHT TO UNRAVEL THE MYSTERY
OF ERIC SWALWELL PEER
JESSE WATTERS, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
THE ONE WHO IS THIS GUY
CUSTOMER'S VEHICLE HE LIKES THE
FINER THINGS IN LIFE.
LIKE MOST LIBERALS WHO WANT
SOMEONE ELSE TO PAY FOR IT, HE
WAS DATING FANG.
BUT HE LOVES THE $90 SUSHI ROLL
IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
THAT COMES WITH CAVIAR AND GOLD
FLAKES.
ALSO LIKES TO FREQUENT, BECAUSE
HE IS A WORKING MAN, THE CHARLIE
PALMER STEAK HOUSE, WHERE HE CAN
GET A $130 STEAK.
AND THAT IS NOT INCLUDED WITH A
SIDE OR A SOUP OR A SALAD.
EVERYTHING IS ALL A CARD.
HE KNOWS THAT.
YOU CAN'T GO BACK TO YOUR MEAGER
HOUSE IN YOUR DISTRICT.
YOU'VE GOT TO WAKE UP THE NEXT
MORNING AND GET 18 HOLES IN AT
THE COURSE THAT OVERLOOKS THE
PACIFIC THEN.
THEN YOU CAN GO BACK TO HAVE
LUNCH THAT SOMEONE ELSE COME OF
COURSE, IS PAYING FOR.
THIS IS WHY PEOPLE HATE
POLITICIANS.
IT'S BECAUSE THESE NARCISSIST
FINGER WADERS GO INTO POLITICS
JUST FOR THE COMFORTABLE
LIFESTYLE THAT THEY WOULD NEVER
BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE OR AFFORD IN
ANY OTHER PROFESSION BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE BRAINS OR
THE TALENT.
SO, IT'S THE NAPA VALLEY, THE
LIMOUSINES.
CORPORATE LOBBYISTS ALL PAY FOR
IT.
AND WE PAY FOR IT, THE
TAXPAYERS.
HE GOES ON IT AND SAYS WE'VE GOT
TO GET BIG MONEY OUT OF POLITICS
AND EVERYTHING IS CORRUPT.
THAT IS THE BIGGEST LIE THAT'S
BEEN TOLD AND THERE HAVE BEEN A
LOT OF THEM KIDS BUT WHEN I GOT
TO ASK COME YOU NEVER REALLY GET
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE SERVER.
WE HAD A PICTURE ON THE SCREEN.
HIS SERVANT OF COLOR.
HE IS GRINNING.
HE IS OBVIOUSLY UNDER SOME
PRESSURE TO PRETEND THAT HE
ADORES ERIC SWALWELL, BECAUSE
ERIC SWALWELL IS IN CHARGE COME
OF COURSE.
HE IS THE GREAT WHITE HUNTER.
BUT WHY WE SUBPOENA THAT MAN,
THAT ON HER VOICE AND LET HIM
TELL HIS STORY?
WHAT IS IT LIKE TO HAVE ERIC
SWALWELL AS YOUR CHIEF, AS YOUR
COMMANDER?
>> I JUST FEEL BAD FOR THE CAMEL
BECAUSE IF HE IS REALLY A
CHAMPION OF WOMEN'S RIGHTS, CAN
HE GO OVER TO HUNTER AND ASK WHY
IT'S ILLEGAL TO BE YOUR WIFE
THERE?
AS SOMEONE THAT SAYS THE WORLD
IS GOING TO END IN 12 YEARS, DID
HE ASK HUNTER ABOUT THEIR
EMISSIONS?
DID HE ASK ABOUT HOW SLAVE LABOR
IS BUILDING THE SOCCER STADIUM
OVER THERE?
I HAVE A FEELING THIS WAS NOT A
FACT-FINDING MISSION, TUCKER.
MAYBE WHEN I SAY FACTS, PROBABLY
DAIQUIRIS IS THE ONLY THING HE
WAS LOOKING FOR.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW, I WAS
THINKING TEQUILA SUNRISE.
I JUST WANT TO PUT A CALL OUT TO
OUR VIEWERS.
IF YOU KNOW HIS NATIVE BEARER,
HE IS APPARENTLY AN ADORING
SERVER.
WE WOULD LOVE